if you can't wait until next week for  Mass Effect Andromeda you can get your  hands on some other space goodies this  week I'm Tony this is a game spot news  update and for all your cosmic cosmetic  needs be sure to subscribe Mass Effect  Andromeda items are coming to rock band  4 including Andromeda initiative  spacesuits and some really rad guitars  modeled after the Normandy and tempest  ships so if you picked up any of the  Daft Punk DLC tracks for the game now  you can go full robot rock this isn't  the first time Harmonix has included  other properties in its music game  either fallout 4 and battle born items  are also available Mass Effect Andromeda  comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on march  twenty first if you don't own rock band  4 but you still want to see more space  stuff stay tuned to gamespot for our  deep dive into the game with the story  of Mass Effect part 1 premieres saturday  the 18th part 2 on sunday the nineteenth  see you in orbit Pathfinder  you